what is happening there citizens of the
reject Nation we are going to watch a
film that I'm sure is extremely
Advertiser friendly for YouTube by all
stretch it's a film called X and I've
never seen the trailer but I know it's 8
24. I know my homegirl Jenna Ortega's in
it what's her name Mia goth she's at all
the talk and I'm like yeah
so very blunt reaction today have you
seen a trailer for this
I saw like an ad a long time ago I know
like a couple Bare Bones ideas but not
much else I'm excited to see what's in
store how are you I am excited I've been
hearing a lot about this so I can't wait
to see what's in store
um but yeah guys thanks for uh
recommending this our way please go
ahead and leave a like that'd be very
much appreciated also subscribe and
click that notification Bell because you
never know what we're going to cover on
here then I pique your interest also uh
full-length Reaction watch along as we
single with your own copy of X we are
watching this off Amazon available for
or super sexy rejects over at our
patreon page thank you to all who
joining we cover several stuff
exclusively over their reaction
highlights and watch alongs included all
right I'm I I don't know what we're
about to watch let's find out
[Music]
as Zack Snyder intended oh this is a
clever shot are we through a doorway oh
good call yeah I love Texas Chainsaw oh
that's clever
yeah nice
[Music]
perfect aspect ratio change yeah
Oh I thought that was an animal
wow that's exactly the Texas Chainsaw
house
I regret to say
I know the powers of Satan Amen brother
creepy
nice transish
satanic undertones and some very overt
satanics
[Music]
cool shot you're special
there ain't nobody else out there like
you I feel like that line is very
important already
you're a [__] sex symbol
[Laughter]
that's what that's how I start my day
digging the framing a lot
plowing
service
[Laughter]
don't worry
[__] and text America America don't
tread on me
very Texas Chainsaw The Farmer's
Daughter Hollywood here we come to no
man we don't need Hollywood these type
of pictures turn regular folks into
Stars we're gonna do it all ourselves
this guy does a great McConaughey
impression
so it sounds an awful lot like what you
said about the topless Car Wash you
remember that yeah and head the IRS shut
up
I was still a good hand people spent a
lot of money to look at what God gave me
is that Britney's no that is Brittany
Snow and that's Kid Cudi oh what Jesus
[Music]
Hurry Up We're Not Gonna Be Long in
there
man these set designs are really great I
deserve and I think I have Cosmopolitan
take don't I know it I mean it all in
the whole world don't know my name
everyone with a pulse is going to lust
after a piece of Mexican makes they see
what you can do all right I've seen Minx
because you're gonna be all over the
news lady your little boyfriend's cute
you help him with all his films
sometimes yeah is that your boyfriend
sometimes
[Laughter]
actually intend on experimented a lot
with the films editor giving it a
certain sense of the iPhone card like
they're doing in France it's classier
that way oh yes elevate your material
all right go ahead and fill her up so
very good
direct Cinema If you tilt the camera up
from the nozzle
it'll look like he's using his
symbolism
I mean you shouldn't expose your jacket
then
exactly something I want to advertise
around town there's some Evangelical
backdrop is very interesting
get what we needed well I got it thanks
thanks to Yours Truly oh my God there's
Sinners that are going to be punished
yeah God's gonna come down himself I
appreciate even with the sound design
they're really committed to it
still a TV station that's the whole
state watches jeez yep
[Music]
but every man has got his limits
oh look at all these cows interesting
are they gonna kill all these cows yep I
love cows there's a cow up close I love
them
what
[Music]
maybe just one oh no
let him go
foreshadowing oh that's horrible I'm
getting too old for this [__] something
tells me it's gonna
really take a very change of like very
attention a very big change into Russian
damage damage you got there it's like oh
Texas Chainsaw but then now it's really
gonna take a change
foreign
voyeuristic angles too very 70s makes
you want to bust out your zoom lens
y'all stay put while I go and handle
business right quick
it's choir music sounds like sacrificial
music yeah foreign
because it is possible to make a good
dirty movie
it's a good fight my dude
read it for the articles
are you from the county
this year's private property
didn't you see the signs down at the end
of the draft
oh easy partner
yeah no cues I'm from Houston now we
spoke on Tuesday
oh that's right uh you had me pretty
nervous there it ain't even unloaded
that that's one of this song [__]
wow we don't even see that guy up close
huh I wonder if it's some kind of
Easter egg character actor and I'll
probably see him again but
Charlie Hunnam
yep
what if it just turns into the visit
oh you know that's the devil right there
you got sin walking on your property
right now lady
Temptation incarnate won't be having any
of this lust and fornification over here
we are a wholesome family God's children
you sure flat feet
I did
two tours in South Vietnam had enough
Farmers trying to shoot me for one
lifetime just like that you made it out
of me yeah I don't recall you mentioning
you'd be bringing all these others see
your head said thirty dollars but
little extra Sweeting the deal I'll take
your 35 dollars
that's a very sweet deal
harmless he's just old he don't know
what we're doing does he
was the glass of course not
he sure doesn't and I intend to keep it
that way
what's better to beg for forgiveness and
ask for permission sir God damn dead
body in there what's with all the Flies
cut to the Chase and we give people what
they want to see
finally
[Laughter]
Kid Cudi I wonder what the audition was
like so you know if you're watching this
on YouTube
all of this is gonna be a lot of it you
can't see right now
I can't tell if Jenna Ortega is enjoying
it or not yeah no she she wants she
secretly wants this life
sloshing water
go for a dip
what could go wrong
now we're on Friday that they're
charista Lake
oh is that the mom
had the wife I mean yeah probably got
more hair on top oh [__] is she the
villain of the movie is it the visit but
damn sure
damn [__] on there well that's because
I'm not treating a lot of pornography
but it's Cinema people's eyes are gonna
pop out of their damn skulls when they
see this foreshadowing
oh wow that's a that's a workplace
scenario
strange inner cutting because back then
they couldn't it took a long time to add
like a dissolve yeah I just put a few
friends okay
oh good when your feet were in the water
I was like I wonder if an alligator
would be in here and then it becomes
crawl or a crocodile
a very cool shot
yeah it's spooky
that is a terrifying shot oh damn
oh that is terrifying all their budget
went into building this alligator
a team of puppeteers
no no no no no no no no
my daddy will be home soon and I'm sure
he could give you a lifts down
would you like to come inside
ah would I
this is like a French
man yeah
absolutely watch a guitar or truffo you
know
what is that
is she being waved over yep follow me
Deary just making some fresh head cheese
hello
that made me jump
I find this all very interesting
a lot of flies in here too
[Laughter]
it's all sweat everyone's just sweating
oh damn we might actually have a dead
body this time
or a disgusting sink
yes it's like every haunted maze I've
ever been to
oh
what a tea party
yeah I was young ones too I'm just taken
right before the first water
not even or not my hours served them
both damn that sucks there wasn't
anything you went through for me back
then acrossed oceans of time to get to
you and the war games
not everything in life turns out how you
expect
this could be your future lady you
remind me of me
beautiful
[__]
[Music]
guys gotta stop hanging by the windows I
wonder why we're intercut into this
daddy catches us
there's no telling what he might do
[Music]
what are you doing
just in time
it'll be our secret
yeah right yeah
it's okay something tells me that
woman's evil yeah and he's actually all
right
he's as protective the rest of us
foreboding music oh my God the kid says
we're going to lose a lot
come on now Chop Chop well she's
definitely in the mood now yeah
get on camera
not except love I do not deserve
so many mantras in this movie so much
lust and greed man
Pride they are the embodiment of the
seven deadly sins
except for gluttony they're all in good
shape
laughs
oh oh
evidence
oh no oh you guys don't go sneaking
this is pretty very this is pretty like
artsy it's good I could give you a ride
whoa
huh
ew oh it's quite a vanity
it's bad news
come on old lady get in there
yeah she wants to jump in
she curious
she also wants to jump in
that is creepy as hell oh yeah she
craves the youth
oh
oh that's you in the future
embrace it I have a weird Theory I
wonder if that old lady isn't it is like
a a younger a much younger actor in
makeup
like it's her like it's me a goth or
something
[Music]
I wonder if she relied so much on her
beauty
foreign
go for it let's do this seduce Him Live
your best life you know I can't
my heart
oh but what a way to go out careful tell
y'all she was something special
thanks baby
oh come on don't be so shy speak up say
you want to be in the film as you wear
your crucifix
foreign
watching her doing it with him as long
as the camera is running
so the camera changes things that's
right it's not real life Randy it's just
a movie I'll run this by my wife yes
absolutely maybe with anyone I want if
there's a camera
decide who you want to
attraction
healthy keeping those feelings locked
away inside I've seen you sneaking a few
long Peaks at Jackson over here no I I
wasn't looking you don't mind none oh no
he's insecure cameraman mines finally
people gonna get to see what datas are
and the privacy of their own homes oh
yeah free of judgment we're going to
give that to them before anyone else on
betamax host of the perverts they've
been paying our bills for years living a
lot of access being young and however on
to the day we die to the power of
Independence Cinema thank you
I don't know if I agree with all of that
but I did like what I saw today I think
I would but I did cheers to that
where is this Sequence gonna land us
yeah
oh splatterfest what awful montage is
this
beginning
this poor old lady she's so old and has
so many desires still us
I want to do a scene in the movie oh
here it is yep yep who's gonna do the
sound
what
no
did y'all put her up to this or
something oh yeah
it's your fault man yeah I mean it
wouldn't make any sense we've already
shot half of it
story can't just suddenly change Midway
just add another daughter why
because it just isn't done
what about on psycho you love that movie
well psycho is a horror film and you're
about to step into one
nobody's coming to see this film for the
plot
plot and a big
oh man you just signed her death warrant
Jenna Ortega she's gonna do it whether
you like it or not now you try to stop
her not only is she going to do it she's
going to go on and do it with God knows
how many people and God knows how many
other films and nobody wants that
the rain is not like the others in there
she is a nice girl wow thank you pardon
no I didn't mean it like that
I hate to be the one to tell you this
girl
[Music]
set up a tripod and get on screen dude
damn what an uncomfortable last position
of being
[Music]
there it is man Satan rains down his
influence you signed your death warrant
oh dude's crying dang
dang no you would not survive 2023 buddy
yeah man
you will not survive the only Fan's era
I wonder if he's the other one who makes
it out of here alive I could see it
or he's about to die or the first one to
die
let's see how far they get without me
good luck finding your own way honey
Don't Fear the Reaper
[Music]
oh why'd you get out
are you all right
what's behind her hand sorry I'm
oh
[Music]
make her dreams come true son get back
at Jenna Ortega
uh what's in her other hand
hope the husband doesn't see this gonna
get his head blown off
how come you just did that
I mean like you looked at her I can show
you what okay stop I I don't want to see
it
oh
it's poor old woman maybe we should just
go find your husband that's not the
solution or leave
leave oh yeah yeah you were right
should have
said yes
whoa
disturbing
foreign
oh my God
whoa
cool lights lighting change
oh buddy
ah
God that is so many I mean I wonder how
many slashes they had to cut that down
from
this is what happens to me
it's what happens when you're a
controlling prude when you say no
she needs to let it out somehow maybe
she can reverse the aging process with
his blood
to how you used to dance yeah she's
Arthur Fleck
I'll go crawl inside the fridge
oh
RJ
I'm sorry she started slaughtering all
them
old ladies finding her youthful energy
again
I woke up and he was gone I
think he left me do you oh huh he's
probably just processing things you know
come back to bed
what if I heard him I want to break up
will you help me find him please cause
I'm worried
I ain't getting in the middle of no more
in this [__]
see we got shoes on
what are you doing out here
looking for my boyfriend
have you seen my wife
sir all right now you two get together
two keys keeping a healthy relationship
never let a good woman out of your side
I never mentioned her weight
there's an art to it
just like business
yo no good
oh oh man no
oh
wow
wow damn it's cool to do one take
me Christ's sakes I'm Gonna Catch tennis
from the [__]
sure
all you gotta do is do it with the old
lady
it's the key
that's how you survive it right
what is that
it's gonna be like a pitchfork or
something
yep
not bad there's another light down on
the cellar
you go get it my wife is not well
it's very dark and I'm worried she could
fall and break her hip
yeah that's that's what you should be
worried about
faster you go about it the better
whoa whoa transitions
oh it was an eye out that was a really
good jump scare
oh is she moving quick
yeah she's getting agile why will none
of you make love to me I think she's
found a new outlet yep
two there you go stab away lady and make
sure he's dead there you go enjoy
yourself
I'll get another poke in there
poke him in the butt
[Laughter]
I think you're right I think there is a
reason there's so many flies all over
this Farm
damn she home alone in them what if
instead of a little kid it was an old
person
found it
hey I'm locked in
damn
open up
the music is just like heavy panting
[Music]
whoa no
yeah
it's a reasonable reaction what a
reaction
oh yeah it is just M2 in the house huh
no no it's me a pharaoh too me a Gothia
and me a pharaoh somewhere in this
universe sure absolutely
those raised babies in the 70s right
my wife
it's gone missing what a far powerful
I'm missing why it's for Gators I found
her once by the edge of our pond
she used to fall in yikes want some help
oh God
yeah I'd do that
maybe some shoes too he did that scene
method too
[Music]
this film is scary
yeah really ominous and unsettling
go lie in bed with her tell her how you
feel you touch her skin
waiting for this
[Music]
foreign
you remember what it was like once
relive The Glory Days
I only got one light
I want some Marine always a marine and
she's out here
I'll find her
where's that hand put her arm around her
come on what are you doing
you can make your move come on
[Music]
just misunderstood John just needs that
Ms Right to come if she sleeps through
anything huh
all that white powder lets her rest easy
yeah oh my gosh she's sucking the youth
out of her what's going on she's a
Dementors they eat her soul
oh nice
pet a little Gator head there
[Music]
ugh damn it man I want to do this and
not oh there's Gators out
[Music]
nah you're safe
this is a creepy film
[Music]
yes arm up
I don't think she's gonna make it out of
this movie alive John uh
uh yeah probably not I just don't want
him to get shot
oh [__]
woof
scare me pops lunch Marine always a
worry
I can't give her what she wants anymore
say what flash bohemian shade here was
the same barely any clothes and Tyson my
wife ah they're both bad yeah
we better get back up to the house and
find out what's going on I know exactly
what's going on
let's
ah
he thinks he's
they're intentionally seducing her
whoa
wake up please for the love of God
I'll do that
me
here's Jenny
oh
no no no she gonna have a brutal ass
death
you can really feel it
[Applause]
nobody's coming for you get back down in
that stuff be quiet
oh there's
oh God
will at least expect in good Christian
homes right on the bare noses see
they're doing the gods work right now
yeah they're doing the Lord's work I
think everyone we've been following are
the bad guys yep
not not these murderers hiding out in
the American Heart are executing sin
that's true extensions of his grace
foreign yes oh my goodness step away
from from The Edge it's dangerous it's
all right here here you're safe now okay
okay
it's just crazy
you don't suspect that it did because
she's an old ass lady yeah what about
becoming a nurse one day
okay
oh damn
why should you get to him at all
was there to be able to just flaunt it
in my face like you do
it ain't my fault you didn't live the
life you wanted oh
move you mean old ugly [__]
right into the gator
[__]
[Music]
a flathead Chomp
[Applause]
was that the one
you know I don't like blondes ugh
they're both evil yeah
yeah that alligator egg crab is that's
good that's visceral that place is empty
and I got another captain of the house
for me I don't want her
that's something special
or god dude oh I'm tired and never
getting what I want
she has it
The X Factor yeah
tell me I'm special
you are you're a professional killer
yeah I feel that way
since the first moment we met oh you all
romantic so they're like the heart of
the movie yeah you still want me
come on
you are way too old to feel young again
I let her have this he's gonna he's
gonna die trying okay
oh man this guy about to die
remember the story of Adam and Eve
oh you're gonna have a heart attack go
for it you crazy kids
oh no what a terrible spot to hide
oh oh
yep yep yep
[Laughter]
this is maybe the most tense I've ever
seen this Trope done
foreign
no
[Music]
Howard about to have a heart attack get
that shotgun blast
stay
[Music]
but did she catch work that one of them
is being kept she must have
I mean
whoa you can go a little way on a flat
tire
oh what oh God okay all right
but is it Lotus I mean I would just run
in there really quick
[Music]
no need to go about this slowly you know
exactly where the old couple is you know
you have a head start and if he dies I
mean she'll be pinned so
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
there's some very Great Kills in here
man
a lot of punch a lot of energy
don't burn upon with the others
they're winning out of the barn is
sinking fuel yeah really good hearing
yeah
whoa damn her face is messed up thirsty
no that's what I'm talking about see
are the case to the truck in the kitchen
we have reach the crossroads she'll come
out when people find out what you've
done
oh I don't think I know who you really
are I thought what you did in the barn
deviant little
oh that doesn't warrant any of this
depend on the flag to me I'm nothing
like you
you're kidnapping murdering sex things
I will not accept a lot I do not deserve
I do not deserve
wow
staring at me
[Music]
well you can still hit her at least
throw it at her
come on come on
whoa whoa kick back
irony nice
on those who accept him praise His name
Gloria bit of Jesus I love how they both
died like that that's so funny
that was great
drop kick yeah double tap just to be
safe
I'll never play you in a prequel
oh dude you're gonna get your head run
over lady
oh lady you're bad come on WOW
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh nice
oh
with the crucifix
jeez nice wide angle
so drive it to an alligator's mouth
swallow the whole truck
my beautiful little daughter Maxine okay
Lord into a life of sin by the very
deviants we want them here on a daily
basis oh she Maxine yeah that I mean
yeah I forgot her name yeah no she's in
the vaccine okay did she know that was
her dad on the TV she must what do you
reckon happened Sheriff
how the hell should I know
[Laughter]
that's a great answer found this inside
put that in evidence let's see what
goddamn Dove heart picture
[Laughter]
wait so is this Pearl movie about Pearl
I guess it must be
that I mean there's a Cinematic Universe
I don't know anything about what you're
talking about it's a bad Universe I
don't I mean I I haven't read much
intentionally but I yeah Pearl they like
I think started working on while they
were working on this and like Ty West
and like Mia goth like wrote it together
and then there's another third movie
called Maxine with three X's that
they're making now okay so they are
actually connected it's not like the ice
cream Brothers
when I said ice cream Brothers I was
like that's the only connected movies I
can think of that have a strong ice
cream thing yeah I can't remember what I
recalled I called the ice cream Brothers
yeah they call that a trolley Sean of
the dead and and those other two yeah
but Spirits these are these are actual
connected
yeah I have no idea how and and why but
yeah okay so she did Play Pearl see okay
there you go yeah you're right about
that oh so she probably came up with the
whole backstory for Pearl and then
Tyler's was probably like oh that's
pretty good he wrote it together yeah we
can uh we can make some of that yeah
that's that's gnarly yeah and they like
both came out in the same year I think
last like last year this is the most
crowd-pleasing tie West movie I've ever
seen
I think it's pretty straightforward yeah
I don't know Ty West's other movies but
there's enough stylistic flourishes and
choices in here to make me think
sometimes it does experimental
independent pieces that go a little too
far off the rails for your mainstream
audience
to a degree yeah but also that are like
very deliberate and and patient and they
take a while and then they kind of
explain like a house of the devil has
that where it's like this is a very
patient movie in the last 20 minutes are
insane oh really whereas this is like a
steady build up throughout
and like his VHS segment is like
one of the slower Burns oh [__] well
[__] John well [__] that's a problem you
watch a movie like this and then you
want to do a terrible Southern drawl the
rest of the day we're gonna talk about
this the whole goddamn reveals all right
brother
preach Yeehaw that'll plug your time out
of there that was the film we deserved
for the lives we deserve gonna get
myself a gator hunting gun
damn
wow all right well now we review it
alrighty ladies and gentlemen well
while I feel like I gotta digest it a
little bit as we go
um
yeah it's kind of interesting I've seen
a few horror movies this year
and this this came out 2022 so I'm not
sure exactly where I would particularly
place it
I enjoyed it quite a bit you know I
thought it did a really good job at
the first thing that pops to mind for me
is I think it did an excellent job at
not only capturing the aura and the
Aesthetics of a 70s horror movie but
really using it as more than just a
gimmick it had a had a powerful affect
on the experience overall with its yeah
you have that dirty scuzzy feeling about
it and while it you know evokes a lot of
the 70s horror movies as the film plays
out it
stops being that and the way they s this
director Ty West did a great job at
subverting expectations in the way how a
lot of deaths went down or even doing
some good surprises for certain things
and does a good job of getting you to
pay attention in a way where it's not
like this
big murder mystery or something like
that but you know it's it's not till
like close to an hour in until moves
about hour 45 and or yeah something
about actual film not counting crowd
it's about an hour 45 and I and I
noticed that like it wasn't until like
close to an hour end until the first
death happens but there's constantly
building the the mood it's constantly
building this atmosphere of
this interesting sin and depravity but
not like full-on depravity it's more of
just the uh messed up ways uh this
Christian America can often uh make
Society feel and it's uh which is which
is neat to have her be the daughter I
thought of like to grow up in a
household because there's so much types
of Oppression that gets judged and often
the ones who are the ones causing the
condemnation to have those same desires
within themselves and then they
retaliate by shaming or
like this is this is like a very extreme
version of that to me you know with this
old couple where I haven't seen this
Pearl moved on what the hell that
happens in that Pearl Baxter but then my
interpretation off of this one
Standalone film first off is it you get
this impression of this judgment that
they bestow upon the way Society is
today and the youth and then like these
guys are the embodiment of it they're
making an adult film look at them just
having their orgies and indulging
themselves and that their sexual deviant
ways but she desires that and she wants
that too you know yeah and they commit
these acts of violence so it was an
interesting
it was an interesting experience because
you're you're so much more in the mood
of it all before [__] starts really
going down
and I thought it did a really excellent
job because I thought it was just going
to be like a Non-Stop Slaughter Fest and
suddenly in the last half hour where
she's like running fast and all that
yeah yeah we should get Supernatural
power yeah yeah but it never it never
divulged into that because I introduced
her as this uh you know helpless senile
lady is very ill and even I was getting
my guesses wrong about like maybe he's
out maybe they're trying to just trick
us like he's all right yeah but she's
she's a cruising one
but actually you know they're both crazy
and it's they're the same people from
when they were young where he just wants
to please her and keep her happy
so I thought it was a very fun
experience uh I thought it was really
well executed
and
disturbing that that wasn't like too
disturbing to me but it was like
reasonably disturbing but it's a yeah
it's effective on this story it's
undisturbing it's like Grindhouse horror
to me it wasn't like yeah
you know it's really it's really like
pulpy yeah and I like how it's practical
effects driven in that department too
yeah I think they they did nicely in a
couple different ways to split the
difference and yeah have it be they did
just the right amount of tributing to to
give you a bunch of preconceived notions
to then tweak and play with uh you know
based off of stuff like a Texas Chainsaw
movie or like a Friday the 13th movie or
any number of others and then they also
give you the 70s style to then go off of
but they also mix just the right amount
it's like it's like you said it's not
just like a gimmick or a filter or
something they put over this they use
the patience of the 70s Vibe and that
directing style and those lens choices
to I think split the difference in a
really nice way because if you watch a
movie like The Texas Chainsaw Massacre
that movie feels like you're there and
it's very spread out in a lot of ways
and it's more violent than you remember
it being uh whereas in a movie like this
you know you still have a lot of that
same patience and a lot of that same
atmosphere and a lot of that same you
know you can feel the heat and the
stickiness but I feel like this in a
side-by-side comparison would be more
outwardly pleasing in a way
because it is uh paced in a more modern
sensibility it has more of a modern
build and so I thought yeah a while so
like a gazillion shots in style so yeah
purely like a 70s film oh yeah
absolutely and again like I I've seen
other movies and other tie West movies
even uh very much adhere to the time and
place in cinema that they are emulating
and and speaking the language of whereas
here I thought it was a really nice
splitting of that difference and that
carries over into the gore and the kills
as well because yeah it is like schlocky
and it is like grind Housey and it is
like more 80s in that regard or yeah I
mean late 70s works too but yeah you
have that sort of naturalistic approach
to like when she gets her fingers
smashed in the door Jenna Ortega like
that's a very icky like real looking gag
but it also plays as this very shocking
very in your face you know thing that in
an earlier time would not look as real
would look a lot more hyper stylized and
so I think they did nicely across a lot
of different parts of this to split that
difference to authentically give you you
know that tribute quality but then use
that against you too those old people
did not look real
like realistically old
they looked like it was like well I
enjoyed looking at the makeup but they
look like so
it's a nitpick I mean I don't know how
much it would really do for me if they
did look real you know but it was like
that it's like such makeup they're so
made up yeah it's like you could tell
like oh they both got fake teeth in and
then he's got like his jaw built way
down to look like a Hills Have Eyes
character like if [__] Keepers fell in
love with this [__] yeah yes absolutely
yeah that's great not that it needs to
be that real for me um I don't even know
I really want it up pointed it out but
it's just that's just one thing yeah
it's it's something you I noticed that
throughout I was thinking about that I
mean I think that's what it really
helped you guess that thing with me at
goth too it's like there's an awareness
that this is not this makeup is so he is
very much makeup yeah and it's funny
because part way through I was like oh
wow like they're really drawing this
mystery like they're not showing their
faces very much what's going on and then
part way through like okay as a country
interest decision because it's creepy
but also it helps these makeups yeah
yeah
well I think the movie is so much about
our
I like okay look get out of the way
everyone does a great job acting ones
thought everyone was great you know and
I like I like these horror movies that
are always a two halves like you got one
half of this movie which only
intermittently checks in with the old
people but the first half is them making
an adult film and the uncomfortable
situations that can occur with that but
are kind of thematically linked with
Jenna Ortega's character because so much
of it is is so much Christian America's
unhealthy relationship with sexuality
you know and her character is like they
call her the church girl church mouse
yeah church mouse church mouse she's the
one who walks around wearing the
crucifix around her neck like she's a
good Christian girl
and and it's her desire for you know the
lustful desire that comes out of her
which the moments preceding the time
where she
um lets out that she wants to be a part
of the adult film
where everyone's talking about like yeah
this is like old ways of thinking and
it's and you know in 2023 today it's
like uh polyamorous relationships are so
common now especially out here in L.A
like they're they're very cool yeah it's
very common now yeah and and it's
something that you know I obviously can
still have a very big stigma around it
and then a lot of people can feel
uncomfortable to like open up about it
or or be honest if they are on one or
something like that uh because uh just
because the way the world is right and
so when they're with that group they're
all talking about it like they just love
sexy and then with her character going
down that change
and then watching it tear apart the
relationship I like how that ends up
being the Segway piece into the
full-blown horror with the old couple
who
has this thing that the sexual desire
that morphs into violence yeah which is
which is such a
like the religious thing was so overt
but it became such a such a such a
presence throughout even though the
movie wasn't even about religion but it
is yeah yeah and I like that you know by
the end of it it's like it sets you up
in a way where you expect certain
characters will be rewarded or punished
for certain things and I think it does
nicely yeah to not leave you there
ultimately because it's like it's like
church mouse makes it almost to the end
and the guy who is the least involved in
what the community around him is doing
is the first one to go and yeah like I
thought this had a i this is a movie
that I would want to chew on and kind of
digest more because I think they're
there's so much of it that's just kind
of your straightforward watching events
unfold but there is I think an
interesting human comment because I I
did feel for the old couple in a way
because yeah I mean they have these
really restrictive beliefs but also they
are just like past the prime of of life
and longing for you know the the spoils
and splendors of being young and what
that affords you
and uh and some of that is very tragic
uh and and that sort of personal tragedy
then bleeding over into this yeah
religious Dogma that I think is nicely
like poked at and prodded without ever
feeling like it's preacher like it's you
know like I'm watching somebody do a
diatribe but through characters or
something like that like this plays
really well as its own movie Just
experience alone and it doesn't seem to
pass too much judgment on any one
character uh which I think is kind of a
nice thing because then that allows you
to bring your own you know Rorschach
test psychology in and kind of
extrapolate as as you please and as you
want and I mean I think the only thing
you can kind of predict going in is like
most everybody will probably die somehow
but the way that all goes down I thought
was was interestingly handled and it
didn't feel too much like
it felt like the situation going to [__]
and then you finding what Twisted
underbelly Lies Beneath all this stuff
and like you were pointing out yeah like
you know people who are watching this on
TV all the time yet are harboring these
latent desires that are just festering
and rotting and boiling over and I think
having them be old
these two like is you know extremely old
and kind of you know
stylized looking people then coming
together and actually making love to one
another and having that not be the thing
that kills them but it gets them kind of
close to there like I think it flirts
with those things that people imagine
when Jenna Ortega runs out she she has
that turn where she's like you're the
cause of all this this is all your fault
like she almost has this turn back into
the extremes of her faithfulness because
it's it's almost kind of uh resigning to
the idea that like God is punishing us
right now because of my Temptation
because of you guys because We snuck in
here and had to do all this and yeah and
yeah it it I think it just gets at that
fulcrum of pleasure that can either
Empower or rot you you know one way or
another and I think it is interesting
that she is the you know I guess you
could argue that she is an escapee from
this particular sect of Christianity
that is all over these TVs that is just
like so prevalent and I think that's
kind of a neat thing for that character
because I guess you always have to
question
I don't know anything surrounding sexual
empowerment that is like authored by a
dude is like something I think you know
needs a certain amount of like an
examination but it is kind of
interesting that yeah she is
you know well entrenched in you know the
the industry that we're spending most of
the first half of the movie looking
through the lens of and yet she's also
having this direct reaction to a
different kind of Oppression that's
masquerading as something Pious whereas
here it's like on the face this is like
yeah this is a sin this is sexual
deviance all that stuff and yet you know
when we peer in on them there's kind of
regular people you know trying to make a
life for themselves and I think that's
the nice thing about that Mantra I don't
want to live the life I want to live the
life I deserve or whatever I won't live
life I don't deserve and her repurposing
that for her own empowerment
yeah that's an interesting twist yeah
I wonder how I feel about that twist
yeah
like
I mean it gives you a kind of an Insight
a little bit more to like ruminating on
what her backstory would be
it is just uh
I don't know I I really don't know how I
really don't know if I even really like
like oh cool
but
is it a little too clever
I'm not really sure I'm curious like the
twist might be like a little too much
for me I don't know if it is though it
might reach
there's again I think there's a certain
uh they're not doing too much magic with
the circumstances Everything feels very
natural and that is one of those things
that feels the most coincidental I guess
or the most it's the detail that is
placed in a way where you can most feel
beyond the camera instead of just what's
happening on screen that's a good way to
put it down yeah and that's that's the
thing I would be curious to again digest
and stuff like I I like it's it's
difficult in this position because you
want to have a fully formed opinion you
know right away but this is one of those
movies that I would want to sit with for
the theme's sake because the ending the
way the ending goes down part of me is
like you could look at this as just a
new twist or a new way to you have your
classic slasher final girl but she is
even further from like there was a time
where it was kind of progressive to have
it be that like it wasn't just the
virginal girl who makes it to the end
like maybe there is a girl who does
indulge a bit throughout the movie but
she still kind of is okay and she makes
it and in this one it's like you know
she's
you know the whole like you can't have
sex and make it through the movie rules
out the window but she's also like you
know she takes a bump at the end as well
and it's like you know she's still kind
of steeped in all these things I think a
character would be punished for if the
movie had actually come out during this
time
um oh yeah I mean I don't think the
movie's on the side of yeah Christian
America no yeah no but but at the same
time it doesn't seem entirely just like
religion bad and that's it you know like
I feel like at least the way it presents
itself gives you again a little more
latitude to consider you know the themes
yeah no I I think they don't
it doesn't become like protagonists
arguing about religion yeah they call
her church mouse and stuff but in the
whole discussion about sexuality before
uh Jenner Ortega's character decides she
wants to be on camera
there's not
uh I don't think there's anything about
God in that moment yeah that was that
guy's personal boundary yeah there's
nothing wrong about Christianity but but
that's the thing is there's so there's
there's so much of a and it's still
evolving in this world you know and it's
a in America especially it's it's so
evolving and there is such an
uncomfortableness
that a lot of us kind of grow up with
every time I go into the sauna oh it
happened today there's always some like
random guys just talking about it and
like what our kids are growing up with
like I'm like this is why is it always
in the song like there's always like
random guys I've never seen the same guy
twice
and the kind of society you're growing
up in you know uh it's because yeah I
mean even even the director of the Wayne
director talks about like the time in
which this movie's taking place places
before people could just access adult
films you know in their
comfortability of your own homes they're
not exclusive to just the creeps you
know perverts whatever yeah you don't
have to be bold enough to go to a
theater yeah yeah now you can just
everyone can indulge it everyone has it
in them at the end of the day you know
and it's that I I like the story of
someone who wants I like the idea of
like this is all a form of repression
just manifesting itself in some weird
way yeah you know and and even for even
even for the general take advantage I
mean a goth character Maxine like in
some ways or her upbringing is so much
about hers you can imagine I like the
Twister what it tells you about the
character of Maxine growing up in what
must have been the strictest Christian
household yeah and preacher's daughter
so much of being judged and being told
you're not good enough and what you're
doing is a sin you're wrong you're going
to go to hell you're going to be
punished and and so much of this is a uh
an act going against that and learning
to be okay with yourself doing all that
you know and so I I appreciate that I do
miss for uh
some of the kind of I don't like
uh this movie John I'd very much
disagree on uh I don't like that Texas
Chainsaw Massacre original movie I don't
I have a really hard time sitting
through it I actually think it's a very
frustrating film
and and uh but what I do like is the
element of the very end of the relief
that the final girl has after the the
crazy turbo oil this woman has been
through and this desperation to survive
and then when she gets away like it's
such an iconic shot in cinema when she's
on the back of the truck for a reason
you know I'm like oh she did it look up
there's all these like variety of
emotions running through her and I and
and and for me I do kind of need that
what a main character gets away after
all their friends die is something that
seems like I just went through hell and
granted she didn't see like all the dead
bodies and whatever but she's probably
picked up on the fact that all are all
dead you know but she's been through a
horror show and there was a bit of a
missing and which is crazy to me because
Mia goth did such an amazing job yeah
throughout the film and as the old lady
like such an amazing job but the the
movie didn't have that button for me of
her having just dealt with like just the
most horrific experience and as much as
there's like these empowering qualities
uh a part that pulls me out is you just
did kind of go through like the craziest
horror show in the world right now if I
was the director and she was just a
little too cool for school at the end of
it for me if I was the director I would
have done a lot one of those one of
those things they they sometimes used to
do back in the day whereas you do your
credits over a long shot and just let
her drive what the credits play as she's
driving and just like breaking down
maybe she's still you know it takes
whatever she needs but but yeah it is a
little bit like hell yeah I just made it
I'm a badass I'm a badass yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah I'm going out to be a star
still and I'm leaving this all behind me
and I think you could do that I think
you could still have that but I I feel
like part of your blender that other
quality ought to have been mixed in a
little bit more because yeah but she I
mean when she when uh when Bobby Lynn
comes in and she's like she was in my
bed and she was touching me like she
seemed really rattled and and yeah like
rightfully so just a little bit of that
on that ending shot would have been yeah
nice yeah instead of just she's a badass
yeah badass or or you know even if you
argue she's in shock she still kind of
comes to cry I feel like you know the
movie is putting it across to you like
but she's kind of a badass though yeah
yeah no I I think you can do Disturbed
but badass I think definitely yeah I
think I'm saying like I want to say
sacrifice the quality that they had
saying Implement with you know we're in
agreement yeah just add a little bit
more of that that shakenness that we
have seen up until this point yeah yeah
that's the that's one part of it
um but the actors are all good I thought
everyone was very natural and um
and and uh they all brought something to
the role like there's all kinds of Arc
types in here but they didn't feel like
archetypes which I really appreciated
yeah like they they really could have
you know and I think for a movie that's
riffing on slasher films which
generally have the Trope of like these
people going out and fornicating and how
hot they're about to get killed I like
how that's such a part of meat and part
of the story it's it's part of the
literally thematically what you're
dealing with in this entire story
uh so I thought that was real I really
appreciate that and I think for
every character that they had here who
was part of the film crew they they
managed to make everyone feel very
natural with writing and performances
and no one felt like they were just
playing stereotypes when they really it
really could have been that like you
actually literally got one black guy
like you could you could have just been
a very stereotypical oh yeah yeah a
marine baby yeah yeah yeah you could
have played him like an actual 70s Wawa
thing yeah and Brittany so could've just
been like blonde ditzy girl or whatever
yeah it's like you can tell these are
actual people felt like people yeah they
feel like people yeah Brittany Snow's
got Ambitions Kid Cudi like you know he
feels that character I was like yeah I
buy that I buy that he's you know this
ex-marine who's yeah well they're still
in his prime to a degree well I think
they flesh out the relationships pretty
well too I mean even for the Howard not
Howard um Wayne for the Wayne character
you know I feel like in another movie he
just would have been like oh you find
out he's just some douchey God he wants
to bang all the other girls I can't wait
to watch his sleeves die yeah yeah he
turns into just some like creep sleazy
dude and you really get the idea like no
I mean I respect what my woman does and
uh but yeah I got a business owner I do
want to run business but you also get
the idea that he cares
like everyone felt the relationships all
worked for me even even Jenna Ortega and
the boyfriend the guy filming like I
thought that all all that worked really
well it was a solid conflict so I think
for a film that managed to do a thing
that was riffing on a certain type of
genre and era they did bring something
unique to it and felt natural and it was
really well executed movie that I feel
like my appreciation for will probably
just grow over time with like literally
a couple of things that I'm questionable
about how I feel about it yeah no yeah
as I think a really good convergence of
classic and modern sensibility and uh
and yeah something that has sort of
Timeless questions but also questions
themes that are very pertinent to the
right here and now and yeah I think it
does also well to again set you up with
certain preconceived notions it's like
old people and these kinds of movies are
always just wallpaper to make everything
creepier but here they're like actually
characters after a while and yeah even
though you are about to watch a bunch of
teens or Young people-ish making love
and then dying it's not in the exact
same package as you would expect it and
even the little peripheral things like
the alligators was a great touch just
like a great sort of Hazard of the
environment
what is an alligator for the elevator
versus crocodile what is an alligator
alligator represent yes let's do that
and wisdom Primal instincts Good Fortune
how do we how do we read into the use of
an alligator
uh I guess well you know there's plenty
of uh Primal Instinct ancient wisdom all
the all the religious themes ancient
religious themes
yeah
yes yes uh I'm not having the wrong word
symbolism
I get her symbolism all right
all right
uh okay or they can really present like
a threat
as spirit animals and civilized
individuality protection and strength
I guess that one works after the 15
different editions we have alligators in
front of us yeah yeah
just trying to protect each other or he
was just like well they were by a
[Laughter]
know this is the thing you'd have to
look out for a good Death kill yeah and
also mad respect uh to how they handle
the kills because even though you know
they're gonna die it's also
uh
uh they would surprise because that like
I think the one that surprised me the
most because yeah you have some good
jump scare ones the one that surprised
me the most was the death of Wayne
because it goes into his eye and it's
just funny yeah but then when it clap
but when it cuts back I'm like I've
never had that before like a like a cut
back to it and it's just being pulled
out yeah like something you've already
seen happen sure and and the jump scares
not him getting and jabbing in the high
the jump scares are getting pulled out
like that that was really creative yeah
yeah absolutely and like they do again
like it's it's another one of those it's
a classic kill and yeah it's the classic
kind of kill you would cut away from and
that's it yeah and then yeah you get you
get the whole aftermath and she buries
him and it just gives you so much extra
little hint as to what really is
happening here well also yeah like
keeping the body count
feeling fresh you know definitely for
the here and now and yeah uh like really
really effective in terms of kills and
jump scares and stuff like that like
nothing felt there weren't really
anywhere I was like ah cheap you know
and I and I don't know if it's a direct
reference to any movie but I actually
really liked that that strange one two
three and now we actually cut to the
next scene or the other you know place
that we're alluding to I thought that
editing transition they kept doing was
was an interesting flourish well it
makes it feel like overlap because it is
overlapping in a way but it's really
inner cutting but I did learn recently
that like back then it was so much
harder to add when you're dealing with
film
a lot of times directors wouldn't even
know what the a dissolve or a fade
whatever might look like until the film
was out
it's such a process now you could just
like drop it in your iMovie you know
it's like really easy and uh so but back
then with film so I appreciate they
didn't do any of that [__] here yeah it
was like well and I wonder if
because it adds a certain there is a
mood to it and it gives it a bit of an
ethereal touch
so uh but it's their time like from an
understanding filmmaking a little bit I
I'm like I wonder if they chose just you
know not to do any type of Fades because
of that yeah you know and he makes that
comment about like I can take the
footage I can put it in any order I want
you know
yeah yeah yeah yeah so even though it's
not like directly like oh he must have
vetted this like there is yeah I think
it pairs nicely with the tangibility of
the filmmaking but I would have loved if
it was the actual final shot of the
movie was while she's driving the film
you know real though yeah close this out
and then it cuts to
and it's RJ at the editing booth and
he's like well what do you think of the
film
do you think this is more RC of more
entertaining is this an elevated adult
film or not yeah it's just with the
whole
caste via Gotham like her makeup and her
Old Woman makeup
well and for a second there I was like
well if any gum actress is playing you
know is playing maybe uh maybe the guy
who plays Wayne is playing Howard or
something you know what if there's some
like time timeline thing yeah yeah
conversions of time happening here at
once either that or I would have loved
if if just afterwards you know it's like
cut to the Evans evidence room and some
cop is like I cut together the footage
they got would you like to see yeah just
play the actual porno all right like
Super 8 or something
um alrighty guys well thank you for
being here I really appreciate
um everyone who suggested this wild film
yeah it was fun and hey we will uh what
was today's what day are we filming this
is and then we'll just end this video
right now we'll talk with you all soon
thank you for being here
[Music]